pogchamps 3 is brought to you by gaiuki as
gayaki celebrates 25 years of regenerative yerba
mate they want to thank you for being a part of
their mission achievement to steward and restore
over 200 000 acres of rainforest come to life
at gaia key dot com slash chess that's fine
it's it's fine right there was nothing i could
do it was oh god keep it going we are about to
practice game with his friend sapnap it's great
to see that that table is getting his last minute
prep in with his good friend seth oh maybe
they're ready for an exam nope that's i think
on top of screen already the right game
against his opponent rain wilson here we go uh
reigns got a bit of a deceiving 703 there uh that
i think he's literally only ever played two games
and rain starts with exactly what we thought he
was going to play okay very good now probably g6
or knight f6 and just to explain in
case you didn't know um the rating the
rating that levy was talking about uh rain
hasn't been using this chess.com account
for any other games but the one game against
the world champion magnus coulson and the last
three games in pogchamps he's stepping into the a
similar pattern that you showed in the magnus game
the capture on f7 but turbo is playing so
fast he didn't see it it's still there he
has bishop f7 this way you always need to look
for checks this bishop is unguarded and you can
move the knight with a check to then pick
up the bishop so taboo has got an and again
three moves straight he's vibing to the music but
he's missing out on a big opportunity oh and now
the other bishop is coming off that's probably
a bad move whatever no it's not whatever elbow
what is this on the screen what is this oh
my god oh my god chat you're lagging out here
guys i'm just dreading that i'm dreading
this so much this isn't his account
i swear i saw him at rank 1 300 yes like last
time he did that's correct oh when he's played
bishop takes b2 we can't really see it but
we feel it the bishop seems to be unbeatable
and sabo has no way of saving them not off to the
bestest of starts that has been made more apparent
yes temple's gonna move his knight so that
he loses at least the rook for the bishop
it's not that terrible though if he realizes that
by moving the knight he will at least capture the
bishop because that doors great bishop is an
important piece when you go for the fianchetto
setup that being this g6 push so at least the
queen on a1 in the corner will be attacking
the other rook uh in the corner too that could be
a dangerous situation i think rain will spot it
actually for rain it might be best
not to even take like see the eval
the eval actually preferred maybe going back
because rain's rook is hanging and the only way
to prevent it is by placing something on f6 or e5
he pushes pawn to f6 we usually warn our students
not to move the palm but actually it's working
out perfectly because double is hanging his bishop
no tabbo that's a one mover man
slow down is this making a few moves
with something beautiful like rook g8
or queen h3 first i like queen h3 first
he pushes d5 to get the rook to the g file
nice nice nice queen h38 very nice very nice
yeah i think that first game against michelle
and i kind of gave us the strange perception
of rayne's skills i i do estimate his ability
around like 1400 if i have to say which puts
him satosh uh i mean there's a lot of those
guys who could beat each other benji fishy is a
so he's so good you better add ludwik to the list
too because i think he is watching our show right
now a lot of vegan number one favorite of the
tournament last i checked he was i think he was
doing a chess piece to your list it was i mean to
be honest it was honestly very accurate um he put
i don't know how how he managed to love
that's the beauty of ludwig as a creator
you know there's like how many chess pieces and
he manages to make a tier list of chess pieces
exciting like i know it's crazy original the idea
and how can you make content out of something as
boring as the chess pieces and that's said by
a chess professional well anna we've made chess
interesting in its chess you know like at the
end of the day we should also give ourselves
a little bit of credit it really is chess
i mean think of a game that's not had any
improvements for thousands of years except the
pawn moving diagonally literally they invented
a rule like because they were bored what's next
so this 2.0 better come out soon because yeah
we are running out of ideas oh it's uh it's
it's bad i mean maybe the ability to use
like if you take a piece for the next move
that piece can act like the piece it just took
i don't know i don't know for maybe only one
turn i don't i'm just saying fiji will we see
checkmate next move though new rules or not it's
checkmate on the board with queen to g2 uh well
yeah oh god okay in the meantime that's fine it's
it's fine right there was nothing i could do it
was oh god game two has just started with a very
classical opening the rui lopez or spanish opening
and double blitzes out bishop to c5 yeah rookie a
i mean there there there's also d6 there's queen
the aggressive way yeah it's not perfect because
probably white can like take and take a pawn in
the center uh but uh i love it because it opens
the position there's going to be tactics like take
you know take and if you take on e5 what
ultimately happens is f2 and e5 tied together
via f6 or d4 yeah like for instance even now
like for example queen d6 knight c6 queen
g3 is already looking or bishop h3 is looking
interesting just getting all the way over here
again that's a difficult pattern to spot that you
could in the future place your queen on g3 because
you see the pawn on f2 and you think that
pawn sees you on g3 you say you don't want
to go there you don't want to vote this gambit
but the bishop on c5 is pinning the f2 pawn and
that's why all those patterns are possible and
bishop a7 was played to his credit now we get
knight c6 double don't hang your queen yes i
think we have seen enough bottas gambits today
it would be ideal to move the queen it's not the
same line as we were describing with the bishop
on a7 the difference is that now when the queen
attacks the c6 knight that knight will capture
the bishop so it's not just a hanging piece it
can capture the bishop of tabo and perhaps the
most cruel thing is that if you play queen a4
that's crazy he sees it if knight a7 queen a4
knight c8 the knight will take both bishops and
if knight takes rook takes the knight now has a
getaway brutal chest is brutal comes down to one
square yeah what a difference it would have made
if that bishop was not going to be hanging even
in that position i think it was chaotic because
e5 is a pawn fork and all that stuff but yes the
two knights being on the same diagonal this x-ray
attack i wonder if after knight takes a7 which is
very likely i think rain will spot that now the
knight is in trouble on c6 and he he has to move
it with a capture he has to make a forcing move
to not lose the a4 knight but after knight takes
a7 will we see queen takes a4 and trying to claim
that the knight on a7 has no way back maybe it's
much more likely though he just takes back on a
seven it's like a snap snap it's right in
his face he doesn't have to think about it
ah well we're about to end uh while there
you are right you're right and the knight
had another capture funnily enough rain is
getting out of these patterns because after
queen takes a4 the knight could have captured the
other bishop on the back rank yes so queen takes
would have led to knight c8 now rain either has to
defend his knight okay very good or jump it around
from c5 to d3 oh double sticks on e4 which was a
free pawn but it comes with the price the price
is the e file the pin and the knight can be won
by a palm push a simple pawn push yeah he's not
realizing that it's not about the queen
ultimately it's the night right so
and then yeah i don't have a plan
i don't have a strategy i don't
have anything oh what do i do here
that's not a bad move bringing the rook to
the semi-open fight attacking the pawn on e4
what is my thing i need a thing someone
someone come up with a thing for me
rain has protected d4 pawn and
is ready to develop his bishop
queen g6 is a good idea pinning the g2
pawn and threatening bishop takes h3
yeah actually seriously
with the debate of the oh but queen queen
of three guards the porn range sharp you
know he moves his queen i move my queen and
then i'm gonna get my bishop out this way
yeah but that idea you could still try
to get that idea and if you bring the
rock to the attack rookie five is on
the board and the potential rook lift
yeah tabo is saying i don't have a plan
and then just rattling off a couple of
gangster moves look at that that really is a
gangster move and the rook is heading toward h5
will he guard the pawn now it's hanging the pawn
on d4 or just go all in with rook h5 anything can
happen with this time please don't go rookie seven
taboo don't go here don't go here ah i'm so scared
i'm so scared rook c7 and rook d7
hit now plays bishop to h3 oh no
after the queen trade the rook can eventually
be taken on a7 oh my gosh just when he almost
played his way back into the game with material
down doubles going for stalemate that's what's
going on i was gonna say that's the final chance
the final hope that you run out of legal moves
but he might i mean but it doesn't even
matter because rain actually wins regardless
oh his community is spamming the well-played emote
it was well played i'm a i'm listen i'm
a letterman it really was a good fight
i'm gonna let him know that was that was a good
game and he's gonna come in here and he's gonna
be all you know oh he killed me and this and that
and um now confidence is everything as we've seen
time and time again michelle had that she she
was like hard on herself she was like i already
messed up and she hadn't she hadn't messed
up it does feel like the psychological side
is getting to the participants too as it
happens oftentimes with chess i always say
it should not be overlooked that you probably
think you're lost before you actually are
lost so it's it's something to to bear in mind
that if you think that you already messed up
look again because perhaps it's not true that you
have messed up and by thinking you have messed up
you will indeed show it on the board that now
you are screwed and after rook f2 there is only
one move and i think doubles just
having the solemn moment he's about
to play a move and he's about to get
checkmated rook f7 is made in one um
he did the same thing i have faith that he'll make
a move in the next 10 seconds uh he did the same
thing versus logic he sat there for a while he
wallowed and there you go king h7 on the board
here comes rook f7 from rayne wilson checkmate on
the board queen of eight would have been stalemate
this is checkmate and what a match this has been
yeah almost come back by trouble rain you were
telling uh taboo right before we went live you
were you felt under pressure in that second game
he had me on the ropes in that second
game i mean i was a pawn or two up but
um he played so aggressive and he just kept
coming and just bringing pieces and i was
really like nervous i was super he was throwing
the kitchen sink at my king side there and
it was nerve-wracking he's got a natural such a
natural aggressive chest instinct he's the killer
thank you i'm gonna go a step further
anna i you know you you and i spoke
obviously you guys can't hear us during the
commentary this is what i was gonna say i
know i know rain won the match tubbo that was the
best attacking plan i've seen in this tournament
so uh you what you need to do is stop
googling openings two minutes before your game
i was just clicking the next arrow as fast as
possible trying to memorize as many as i could
for upcoming matchups rain you're taking on uh
you're taking on maybe the other kind of big dog
in the group and that and that's logic have you
visualized how that's gonna go you're gonna assert
dominance there be you know win the group how are
we feeling um well i'm certainly gonna try and win
the group um but yeah i haven't seen logic's
games um i understand he's pretty good and um
a super solid player and you know it's this is
really nerve-racking this whole experience like
i was talking to a friend about it it's like
even when i go on like chess.com and i'm just
like playing a stranger like i get sometimes
i get like that kind of adrenaline of like oh
screw up um but then you know like tens
of thousands of people are watching you
like they're watching my and then you
make a dumb move and you're like wow
67 000 people watched me do that dumb move and i
could have taken that piece right there you know
and so it's it really messes with you but um
i hear logic's great and i'm gonna have to
look at some of his games and and uh hopefully
danny's available to give me some coaching uh
uh in the next day or two uh get get honed up
tempo my my son is 16 he loves your videos man
oh thank you he's a big big fan he's like oh my
god you're gonna play tubbo oh that's amazing oh
that's awesome thank i you john a music connection
too because both of you i think have a nice
collection of instruments double can you show some
of the instruments behind you thank you very much
it is the still pan or drum
sorry this is this is my one
oh nice i think it's a bit i bought it
purely so i can do the start of under the sea
that is the whole reason i have this
oh my god thank you so much for showing it and
rain i think you have uh another instrument nearby
you yeah i got my bassoon right there amazing
the bassoon i've got a little guitar down there
you know yeah it's all right around
anna have you played instruments
i'm trying but i feel like a very much not
talented person in the company of these gentlemen
i've played a few instruments over my life and now
you know like a good chess player i play nothing i
just play chess and that is what i do uh but ford
is your instrument there you go that is beautiful
that is beautiful um and uh gentlemen thank you
those were fantastic games uh we go back to the
drawing board you both have match-ups coming
up so we wish you all the best in those future
match-ups and uh taboo thanks for staying up late
once again we'll see you uh we'll see you when we
see you in a couple days i appreciate it thank
you for having me you guys i'll catch you later
bye
you